[Música]
por qué
porque tenemos la necesidad de fingir
que todo es perfecto porque escondemos
lo que sentimos hasta que ya no podemos
más hoy vengo a compartir con ustedes
cuatro palabras fundamentales
hablemos de nuestros sentimientos
suena muy fácil no
desgraciadamente es inexplicablemente
difícil para muchos de nosotros pero a
pesar de esto vale la pena y es
necesario intentar día a día hablar
sobre lo que sentimos
porque estoy tan segura y soy tan fiel
defensora de esto
bueno pues porque a mí está hervir de
conversación me salvó la vida
hace dos años aproximadamente yo me
encontraba en un lugar muy oscuro
mentalmente y estaba sin rumbo alguno
pero por fuera todo se veía
absolutamente perfecto estaba rodeada de
gente que me ama y en la que amo
académicamente me va bien mi situación
familiar era más que estable y tras
mucho esfuerzo me acababa de ganar una
beca para la escuela de mis sueños por
todo esto y mucho más
mi exterior sonreía pero por dentro no
pude evitar sentirme sola me encontraba
sin motivación y sin ganas de vivir pero
por encima de todo me sentía egoísta e
indigna de luchar por mí misma me decía
el típico sofía no tienes derecho a
sentirte así de mal cuando hay personas
en condiciones verdaderamente negativas
que logra ser feliz y positiva
pero ojo
esta lógica está completamente mal
porque cada sentimiento o percepción y
emoción que tenemos son enteramente
válidos todos merecemos ser escuchados
hidratados pero desgraciadamente y esto
no sucede así
de hecho según la oms el 95% de las
personas con alguna enfermedad mental
nunca son tratadas esto significa que de
cada 100 personas que necesitan ayudar
solamente 5 las reciben
qué podemos hacer para disminuir esta
falta de reconocimiento hacia la
importancia de la salud mental empecemos
por la concientización cómo logramos la
concientización a través de tres pasos
primer paso habla con todos los que
puedas preguntarles a tus seres amados
si están bien hazles saber que estás ahí
pide ayuda si lo necesitas segundo paso
ahora te en el momento en el que estés
lista listo sobre tu lucha personal
contra enfermedades mentales como lo
podría ser la ansiedad o la depresión la
tercera y más importante es educarnos
poseas alguna enfermedad mental o no
estos tres pasos son fundamentales para
lograr la concientización aspecto tan
necesario ya que aparte de que nos ayuda
a entender la importancia de la salud
mental también es uno de los cuatro
pilares fundamentales para una mente
saludable estudios realizados dentro del
campo de la neurociencia nos dicen que
estos cuatro pilares son la
concientización la conexión la
perspectiva y el propósito aunque se
refiere cada uno de estos pilares bueno
pues la concientización se refiere a
estar al tanto de que existe un problema
para así poder tratarlo resolverlo la
conexión se refiere a formar relaciones
interpersonales que te nutran que
traigan un sentido de compasión y
correspondencia la perspectiva se
refiere a cambiar nuestro chip y
eliminar el negativismo de nuestra
narrativa personal y por último el
propósito se refiere a tener un sentido
de la dirección de nuestra vida pero
sobre todo a siempre reconocer
de ésta
hoy estoy aquí para cumplir con estos
cuatro pilares y para lograr un gran
sentido de concientización así que les
punto con total apertura que hace dos
años mi alma estaba cansada y todo un
poco estaba sin ganas de intentarlo una
vez más porque llevaba luchando
silenciosa pero rigurosamente por más de
un año
así que me permite a mí misma soltarme y
lo intente
intenté suicidarme
por suerte no lo logré pero los meses
que siguieron fueron muy difíciles y
bastante bizarros lo único que me queda
claro hoy en día es que me sentía
sofocada por el recuerdo de lo que había
sucedido y por el sentimiento de culpa
por el dolor que le había causado a mis
seres amados
mis papás principalmente se sentían
enteramente responsables de no haber
notado mi lucha de no haberme ayudado
por aquí la verdad es que nada
definitivamente nada de esto fue su
culpa
porque yo vivía y sonreía con entera
normalidad
yo fingía estar bien porque cree que si
lo hacía lo suficiente hasta yo me la
iba a querer
pues eso no funcionó y en el momento en
el que me percaté de que necesitaba
ayuda no la pedía tiempo porque porque
yo veía que en nuestra sociedad el hecho
de querer encarar a la muerte por
decisión propia genera reacciones que
van desde la lástima hasta el desagrado
y yo no quería ser etiquetada de ninguna
de estas maneras
yo no veía salida que pudiera funcionar
me y me culpaba a mí misma por eso pero
hoy en día me doy cuenta que ese dolor y
esa desesperanza que yo sentía no
significaban que fuera débil o indigna
de luchar por mí misma que el hecho de
no ser capaz de pedir ayuda tampoco era
mi culpa porque yo quería poder alzar la
voz quería poder obtener cualquier tipo
de ayuda estaba consciente de que la
necesitaba estaba consciente de que al
guardarme todo lo que sentía me estaba
haciendo más daño
pero yo no tenía la confianza de abrirme
de esta manera
y es justo por esto que se tienen que
abrir la plática porque como yo hay
muchísimas personas que se han sentido
de esta manera
hay que construir un mundo en el que sea
una conversación activa y segura
hay que hablarlo no dejemos que nada nos
detenga de alzar la voz personalmente he
escuchado varias afirmaciones que dicen
que la depresión y la lucha por la salud
mental se han puesto de moda
con esta mente cuando escuchar estos
comentarios me causaban mucha
frustración porque se notaba una gran
falta de empatía y un nivel preocupante
de ignorancia hacia un tema tan
contundente y la importancia de una
conversación constructiva sobre este
pero en un momento en el que me deje de
hundir en el enojo supresión y rechazo
que esto que yo escuchaba me hace sentir
me di cuenta que estos comentarios son
enteramente reales
que tienen que tienen toda la veracidad
del mundo y la realidad es que yo me
siento sumamente orgullosa de que así
sea porque si te es más fácil entenderlo
procesarlo de esta manera en efecto se
están poniendo de moda ya que por fin se
está perdiendo el miedo de combatir
abiertamente las enfermedades mentales
se está alzando la voz iniciando una
plática abierta y segura y en efecto
todos los que hablamos sobre nuestra
lucha en voz alta y defendemos la
importancia de la salud mental estamos
enteramente en búsqueda de atención no
hacia nuestra persona sino que hacia el
tema porque es necesario para lograr la
concientización porque para que todos
nos podamos abrir e iniciar el camino
hacia la superación se tiene que tener
la confianza tiene que existir un lugar
seguro
mi sofía de hace dos años buscaba un
sentido de confort y entendimiento
en los testimonios de aquellas personas
que habían pasado por situaciones
similares a las mías y aunque aunque mi
psicólogo psiquiatra amigos y familia me
decía algo que no solamente iba a salir
bien sino que con mucha fortaleza y
lecciones aprendidas yo no les creía así
que buscaba pruebas y las historias de
aquellas personas que se sentían como yo
eran una gran esperanza porque me hacían
ver que yo también iba a poder salir en
que tal vez algún día estaría en la
posición de conciencia y estabilidad
para poder hablar de lo que yo he pasado
y tal vez ayudar a otra persona
invito a todos a recuperarnos en voz
alta para que alguien más no tenga que
sufrir en silencio
hoy estoy aquí compartiendo mi historia
sin miedo alguno y en búsqueda de
deconstrucción hacia el miedo que existe
frente en la concientización del
suicidio
porque antes de hablarlo para superarlo
yo solía hundirme dentro de cosas
verdaderamente insignificantes me
preocupaba de la vida y de lo que
pasaría así me permitía sentirla
pero en el momento en el que alce la voz
primero internamente y después tras
mucho trabajo con otras personas esos
sentimientos y el dolor que tenía ya muy
aferrados a mi ser fueron desapareciendo
tan discretamente que no me di cuenta de
que esto estaba sucediendo hasta que mi
preocupación cambió completamente no
desapareció sino que el reflector de
esta hora estaba en qué pasaría si no
vivo mi vida lo que perdería lo que no
aprendería a los que abandonaría y
aquellos a los que no conocería
no me sane mágicamente un día la
realidad es que eso no existe pero
aprendí a aceptar que está bien no estar
bien está bien perderte siempre y cuando
te levantes para volverte a encontrar y
sobre todo aprendí que para levantarte
está completamente bien alzar la voz y
pedir una mano de ayuda
muchas gracias